[Music]
from the production company behind two
separate denise richards horse movies
comes a high octane low budget action
caper that finally answers
what if tommy wiseau loved michael bay
movies instead
of erotic dramas
oh hi mark money plane
take to the skies aboard the money plane
a flying casino where you can gamble on
anything death or animal related
man versus cobra you want to bet on a
dude an alligator
money plane sure you could place bets on
those things from anywhere
but only on the money plane can you do
it next to weird perverts rules were
meant to be
then get served a bunch of airplane food
then get shot in the head for cheating
in this feature-length mystery of
whether the people who made this thing
are actually serious
it's a film so alternatingly silly and
boring it's hard to know what's
commentary on the limits of low-budget
filmmaking
and what naturally happens when the dude
from blossom is the most experienced guy
on set
stop stop looking into the camera joey
lawrence this isn't cats
you aren't judy dench high-flying
wrestler edge stars
as jack reese who gets to show off his
gravity-defying moves
never as they cram his massive bug-eyed
ass into a tiny cockpit
for the entire movie pack up the money
you cover your tracks
get the hell out of there he's an expert
thief who openly talks about his
hijacking plans in front of the other
passengers
i have to take control of the cockpit
discovers mid-heist that airplanes have
co-pilots
and always has the look of a guy who's
crying and failing to think of a
comeback
how about i just blow your brains out
i'll create my own damn pollock
now go get me my money jack
[Music]
have a safe flight
he's tasked with taking down the money
plane by feared gangster darius emmanuel
grouch iii
aka the rumble played by kelsey grammer
in a turn so maniacal he's still
crapping out little bits of scenery to
this day
i don't give a who's on that plane
i'm the baddest on the
planet
not since tim curry in command and
conquer riddler 3
has a character actor achieved such
majestic heights over the course of
maybe two hours of filming
including launch your families are all
dead you your crew
and everyone you ever met by the time
you touch down
i'm escaping to the one place that
hasn't been corrupted by capitalism
space joining jack will be a crack team
including isabella an elite operative so
intimidating her opponents stand around
in awe
allowing themselves to be slowly
murdered
trey who's there for no discernible
reason the third lawrence brother
because the only way andrew can get a
bigger part than matthew and joey
is by directing the movie himself and
several of the most unnecessary lower
thirds in movie history probably not
great that i can't tell this by looking
at the set
you can't even disclose it to us the
audience yes
this is where we've been the whole time
there are only two rooms on this plane
separated by a shower curtain
we know where we are so plunk down 3.99
or wait until it pops up on crackle for
the most straightforward heist in film
history
where the high-tech vault can be opened
by taking out a single man
the entire system is compromised by an
idiot on the ground and escaping is as
simple as strapping on a parachute
but not actually skydiving because they
blew their money on cinema's weakest
wind machine
in a film so dumb and so lazy
you have to wonder what the pitch
meeting was like
so you have a movie for me yes sir i do
it's called money plane
oh so it's a movie about a plane filled
with money or is the plane made of money
it's a money plane metaphorically
speaking sir disappointing but okay
see the whole thing is that rich
criminals ride on this thing so they can
gamble why can't the criminals just
gamble on the ground well they could but
see they want to do like
illegal gambling about murder and stuff
so they got to take to the skies
oh airborne criminals are tight yeah
they are so this money plane has a whole
bunch of rules that they have to follow
criminals do love following rules
they sure do sir also crime just kind of
feels better when it's over
international waters
well yeah everybody knows that so anyway
this evil gangster named darius emmanuel
grouch the third he decides he wants to
rob the money plane
no further questions about that guy's
name well i have further information on
it sir he goes by the rumble he tells
people to call him the rumble he
self-identifies as a rumble so who we
think in here sam
jackson ving rhames i was thinking
kelsey grammer oh
frasier the salad tosser himself kelsey
can't wait to phone it in
he's not gonna try very hard no he'll
take it to an eleven he'll just do most
of his scenes via facetime video call
saves us more money for the money plan
exactly so the rumble forces this thief
named jack who's in debt to him to rob
the money plane of all the cash and
cryptocurrency on board i thought the
whole point of crypto was that it has no
physical location well this one does
it's on the money plane fair enough
and the only man good enough to take
down the money plane is this guy jack so
the plan goes smoothly no it's a
complete disaster and he's totally
incompetent and nobody really knows what
they're doing got it so this movie's
about a heist plan that goes wrong
a bit a bit just a little bit of the
movies about this heist well it's gonna
be hard to make a heist movie where we
don't spend time on the heist
actually it's gonna be super easy barely
an inconvenience
oh really yeah we're just gonna kind of
hang out on the money plane not heisting
just kind of vibing just straight vibing
yeah for pretty much the entire second
act oh that kind of seems like a long
time well this is when we get to see all
the crazy bets happening over
international waters on the money plane
okay gotcha so we're gonna have some fun
with the crazy bets
a lot of fun because it's the money
plane yeah yeah and that's why the
criminals have gotten on the money plane
instead of going to vegas where there
are nice hotels and restaurants and
concerts and stuff yeah they go on the
money plane instead of to the city
that's all about gambling and definitely
has weird underground places for this
kind of stuff so what are some of these
bets anyway oh well there's one where a
guy gets his arm cut off
okay so what what's the bet is a guy
gonna cut another guy's arm off i guess
how's how do you bet on that they also
have one bet about a guy having sex with
an
alligator what what aspect of that are
they betting on oh unclear but it's
worth talking about in this movie for
sure well let me ask you something how'd
you get into my office
money plane storing
i'm thieving on a bet plane don't know
when i'll be back again
hello seattle i'm threatening p.i jane
the real housewives of money plane the
fight attendant
air dud ivan the terrible actor
and the brothers dim stakes
on a plane
texas hold'em is about to begin in the
main casino floor
poker thank goodness we're over
international waters so we can play this
exotic and illegal game that's regularly
televised on gsn
god damn
thanks for making me feel alive thank
you for joining us pitch meeting guy
if you liked what you saw check out
screenrant for more it's super easy
barely an inconvenience and then he did
a back flip
snapped the bad guy's neck and saved the
day
being honest about movies is tight
i get my epic voice from my mother